[Musik]
worauf ich mich eigentlich hier
freiwillig zur berlinale in berlin bin
am meisten freue ist dass man in der s
bahnen in der u bahn und auf der straße
und überall menschen begegnet die auf
dem weg ins kino sind oder von dort
gerade hier kommen
das bin ich immer eines der schönsten
elemente dieses festivals das ja
wirklich wie kein anderes der großen
festivals ein publikumsfestival das
worauf ich mich ganz besonders freuen
ist ein film wo alle anderen oder viele
andere sagen das ist nämlich ein film
von wieder ein film von labbadias von
den philippinen vor zwei jahren kam er
mit einem film in den wettbewerb hat
auch einen silbernen bären gewonnen der
achteinhalb stunden dauerte und ich fand
das ganz wunderbar meryl streep übrigens
auch die damals der jury vorsatz in
diesem jahr hat er quasi im kurzfilm
mitgebracht sind muss etwas mehr also
sind deutlich unter fünf stunden also
das kann man gut durchsetzen ohne pause
und es gibt trotzdem mit pause und
darauf freue ich mich ganz besonders
dieter kosslick meint dass der
ultimative film me too debatte ganze
läuft im wettbewerb der wie ich also auf
wäre sparen
[Musik]
und ansonsten gibt es viel afrikanisches
kino das bestimmen
wunderbar es gibt eine james benning
alten james bond film auf denen
ebenfalls der freude erwarten bei putin
heißt der graf im form und dann gibt es
für berlin glaube ich noch mal ganz
besonders schön einen eine
wiederaufführung der wunderschön
restaurierten fassung von den wenders
über
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sagte kosslick in der der
festivaldirektor dieter kosslick in der
pressekonferenz ich begrüße jeden jede
frau im flachen schuhen und wie jeden
mann in high heels auf dem roten teppich
und ich hoffe dazu wird das kann
und ja insofern freue ich mich dass es
jetzt endlich losgeht
[Musik]